every movie would be made better with a
Muppets remake
ooh oh I'm going to have to strongly
agree on that if you were going to make
a
remake of Dune right uhhuh with Muppets
that would be cuz I just want to see
Zinda as a muppet you know what I mean
she still be amazing should be yeah she
would be she would be just just
beautiful this is captivating eyes wi
shut Muppets eyes
wi Muppets with masks on
yeah that would be hard call me by your
name Muppets call me by your name
Muppets like I'd like to see like the
Matrix Matrix Muppets all that green
screen all that green all that green or
a liveaction Muppets could you imagine
just a little frog kit like can you
imagine Kermit is just a real frog kit
impression um Kermit oh I almost just
said Kermit the Frog here is that right
that was great Kermit the Frog here for
Muppet news